quién puede lograr la paz negociada en
Ucrania los ojos de la comunidad
internacional están puestos sobre china
tras la llamada entre she'sky la primera
comunicación directa desde que empezó la
invasión Rosa Beijing confirmó el envío
de una delegación china Ucrania
encabezada por el exembajador chino en
Moscú china mandará al representante
especial del gobierno chino para los
asuntos euroasiáticos a Ucrania y a
otros países para tener una conversación
profunda con todas las partes sobre una
resolución política a la crisis de
Ucrania como gran aliada de Moscú y
potencia mundial china es escuchada por
ambos bandos
hay una oportunidad para usar la
influencia política de China para
restablecer El dominio de los principios
y las normas en que debe basarse la paz
Ucrania y China como la mayoría del
mundo están Igualmente interesadas en
reforzar la soberanía de las Naciones y
de la integridad territorial
más escéptico con la mediación china fue
el jefe de la otan la organización
responsable de la resistencia militar de
kiev
esto no cambia el hecho de que china ha
sido incapaz de condenar la guerra
ilegal de Rusia la invasión ilegal de
Ucrania
pero más allá de la responsabilidad que
china quiera asumir es incierta la
influencia que pueda ejercer sí sobre
Putin
estamos dispuestos a recibir cualquier
cosa que lleve al fin del conflicto en
Ucrania y al cumplimiento de todos los
objetivos establecidos por Rusia Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva también erige a
Brasil como líder de una tercera vía
todos piensan que tiene la razón que son
más fuertes pero la única verdad es que
la gente está muriendo lo que tenemos
que hacer es detenerlos y llegar a un
acuerdo
incipientes esfuerzos diplomáticos
mientras sobre el terreno Ucrania
prepara la supuesta contraofensiva de
primavera con la incógnita de si ayudará
o disuadirá un encuentro alrededor de
una mesa de nego